avec vous parce que vous avez une mesure
à nous annoncer en exclusivité dans
touche pas à mon poste et c'est très
important pour nous aujourd'hui après on
va rappeler le numéro mais parce que
c'est très important
oui dans la grande dans le cas de la
grande cause du quinquennat du président
la république emmanuel macron qui est
donc l'égalité femmes-hommes le
gouvernement présente un projet de loi
qui actuellement à lecture au conseil
d'état ya les trois volets vous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure c'est à dire
qu'on va interdire le harcèlement de rue
et ça c'est important de ce que huit
jeunes femmes sur dix nous disent
qu'elles ont peur quand elles sont
toutes seules le soir je crois que c'est
pas acceptable en france en 2018 donc on
verbalisera le harcèlement de rue
ensuite on va allonger d'élever les
délais de prescription pour les crimes
sexuels commis sur mineurs pour que même
adulte on puisse aller déposer des
plaintes pour des viols subis quand on
était un enfant et troisièmement on crée
un âge on propose pour l'instant l'âge
de 15 ans en dessous duquel on considère
qu'un enfant n'a pas pu être consentant
un rapport sexuel avec un adulte c'est
important de dire que c'est de la
pédophilie de la pédocriminalité et de
dire aux jeunes aux enfants que personne
ne peut les toucher sans leur
consentement
ça ce sont les trois premiers volets
c'est ce que vous avez déjà annoncées
exactement et on ajoute un quatrième
article qui est actuellement en lecture
au conseil d'état et je vous l'annoncé
ce soir dans touche pas à mon poste
c'est un article qui concerne le
cyberharcèlement le constat de base
c'est que dans ce tour de france de
l'égalité femmes hommes dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure tous les lycéens
tous les collégiens quel que soit
l'endroit où ils habitent en france nous
parle des phénomènes de cyber
harcèlement de mon travail avec les
réseaux sociaux les hébergeurs de
contenus etc
mais c'est pas suffisant on veut
renforcer la loi donc cet article il
propose de faire en sorte que quand vous
avez participé à des phénomènes de
cyber-harcèlement vous puissiez être
condamnée même si vous n'avez envoyé que
deux trois mails ou quelques tweets
quelques statuts facebook quelques
messages sur des forums
eh bien vous avez participé un phénomène
de meute qu'en dix vingt cent personnes
se mettent contre une personne et le
harcèle aulas recèlent souvent ce sont
des femmes et d'un considère que vous
pourrez aussi être condamné donc on va
renforcer les condamnations pour cyber
harcèlement je vous l'annoncé aux
accents
mme harel
merci avec vous vous demandez pas ce que
demain vous allez avoir plein de
questions d'autres journalistes qui vont
vous dire pourquoi être voilée ce jour
si important dans touche pas à mon poste
donc je vous la pose moi même comme
sûrement vous n'aurez plus besoin d'y
répondre pourquoi vous êtes venus vous
m'avez invité non plus sérieusement non
vraiment la vraie réponse mais qui n'est
pas particulièrement drôle mais qui est
la vérité c'est parce que vous avez pris
le temps de savoir quel message on avait
envie de faire passer
vous avez pris le temps que l'on se rend
compte qu'on prépare l'émission vous
avez travaillez vous avez préparé ce
qu'on pourrait dire ensemble pour faire
une bonne émission et je crois que c'est
profondément c'est parce que vous
respectez vos téléspectateurs et voter
les spectatrices vous voulez leur
proposer une bonne émission
donc j'étais parfois pour vous suivre
bah merci merci marica pas